[موسيقى]
اكثر من عقد مضى على قتل قوات الخاصه
الامريكيه مؤسسي وزعيم تنظيم القاعده
اسامه بن لادن والاب الروحي لفكره الجهاد
العالمي في مسكنه في ابوت اباد بالقرب من
العاصمه الباكستانيه اسلام اباد ودمرت قبل
ذلك البنيه التحتيه لتنظيم القاعده في
افغانستان وقتلت واعتقلت معظم قادته لكن
ذلك لم يكن النهايه لما اعلنته الولايات
المتحده ومعها المجتمع الدولي بالحرب على
الارهاب بعد صدمه احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر حيث شهد العقد التالي على مقتل ابن
لادن ولاده مرحله اخرى من الجهاديه
العالميه مع ما عرف بالربيع العربي ولم
يقتصر هذه المره على ما تفرع من تنظيم
القاعده من اذرع في سوريا والعراق وليبيا
وتونس والمغرب واليمن وغيرها بل جاء ايضا
من يسرق الاضواء منه منذ اللحظه الاولى
لصعود ابو بكر البغدادي منبر جامع الموصل
الكبير في العام 2014 للاعلان عن تعيينه
خليفه للمسلمين وزعيما لتنظيم الدوله
المعروف اعلاميا بتنظيم داعش بسوريا
والعراق ملتحقا بصفوفه في عام واحد ما قدر
ب 30 الف مقاتل اجنبي من خمس وثمانين دوله
بعد خمس سنوات انقضت قوات التحالف الدولي
لمكافحه الارهاب الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده على اخر معاقل تنظيم داعش ببلده
باغوز السوريه في فبراير 2019 وبعد عده
اشهر وفي العام نفسه قتلت البغدادي مؤسس
وخليفه التنظيم اليوم وحتى بعد اعلان
الولايات المتحده عن مقتل ايمن الظواهري
زعيم تنظيم القاعده في العاصمه الافغانيه
كابول حذر مؤخرا مكتب الامم المتحده
لمكافحه الارهاب من ان التهديد الذي يشكله
تنظيم داعش والجماعات الارهابيه للسلام
والامن الدوليين لا يزال مرتفعا على الرغم
من الخسائر في صفوف قياداتها حتما ان
الحرب العالميه على الارهاب والتطرف هي
معركه طويله مستمره وبالرغم من مضي اكثر
من عقدين على انطلاقتها لا تزال الاجهزه
الامنيه الدوليه المعنيه بمكافحه الارهاب
تعمل على تطوير استراتيجياتها وقوانينها
في حلقتنا اليوم نناقش مشروع الخطه
الاستراتيجيه العربيه لمكافحه الارهاب في
صيغتها المطوره التي تم رفعها لمجلس وزراء
الداخليه العرب من قبل اللجنه العربيه
العليا للمكتب العربي لمكافحه التطرف
والارهاب بعد اجتماعها الذي استضافته
جامعه نايف العربيه للعلوم الامنيه بمقرها
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض فما هو مشروع
الخطه العربيه المطور لمكافحه الارهاب وما
هي ملامح بنودها وما التحديات القائمه
امام تنفيذ بنود الاستراتيجيات العربيه
لمكافحه الارهاب انا هدى الصالح وهذا
برنامج جماعات ارحب معكم اعزائي المستمعين
والمشاهدين بضيفنا الاستاذ خالد الحرفيش
وكيل جامعه نايف العربيه للعلوم الامنيه
حياك الله معنا استاذ خالد
ابغى استهل حديثنا في هذه في حلقتنا اليوم
واسالك بخصوص
المشروع اللي تم رفعه من قبل اللجنه
العربيه لمكافحه الارهاب اللي هي تابعه
لامينات مجلس وزراء الداخليه العرب شو
التطوير في هذا المشروع او هذه
الاستراتيجيه
شكرا لكم استاذه هدى حقيقه مجلس وزراء
الداخلي العرب عبر استراتيجياته العربيه
الامنيه المختلفه ومنها الاستراتيجيه
العربيه
الامنيه لمكافحه الارهاب والتطرف
يسعى جاهدا لمكافحه الجريمه والارهاب
والوقايه منها
للمجلس عدد من الاستراتيجيات منها هذه
الاستراتيجيه والتي
لها خطط تنفيذيه
تنفذ كل خطه تنفيذيه عبر ثلاث سنوات
نفذت حقيقه هذه الخطط في الفترات الماضيه
من عام 97
ميلادي الى الان
وكان لها حقيقه اثار ايجابيه في الوقايه
من الارهاب او مكافحته
وتقليل شروره
اتت هذه
[موسيقى]
التحديث لهذه الاستراتيجيه وهو عباره عن
مواءمه
ما تحويه الاستراتيجيه العربيه من قوانين
من انظمه ومن بعض التعريفات مع
الاستراتيجيه الامم المتحده المقرره في
والهدف انه مقاربه هذه الاستراتيجيه
العربيه مع استراتيجيه المتحده كلف المجلس
الوزراء الداخليه للعرب الموقر
الامانه العامه او شقيه للمجلس هناك شفطين
الامانه العامه للمجلس وجامعه نايف
العربيه للعلوم الامنيه وهي الجهاز العلمي
لمجلس وزراء الداخلي العرب بتحديث
الاستراتيجيه مع المكتب الامم المتحده
المعني
الارهابي نيويورك تمت
فورا بعد اقرار او توجيه اصحاب السموم
المعالي وزراء الداخليه العرب بدا المكتب
العربي لمكافحه الارهاب والتطرف وهو احد
مكات الامانه العام المتخصصه في تشكيل
لجنه عبر بالتنسيق مع الدول العربيه ومع
مكتب المتحده وجامعه نايف وفعلا تم تشكيل
لجنه عليا بدات اجتماعاتها على مدار العام
السابق عقدت 6 اجتماعات وكان اجتماعات
سابع في مقر الجامعه في مدينه الرياض
وبخلاف عدد من اللجان المعنيه بتحديث هذه
الاستراتيجيه لمواكبه المستجدات الراهنه
سواء على تطور
[موسيقى]
الاجهزه العصريه او على مكافحه هذه الدول
اللي شاركت واللي حضرت الاجتماع يعني حظر
الاستماع 14 دوله عربيه عاده في مثل هذه
الاجتماعات هناك طبعا لجان مسبقه تتم من
جميع الدول العربيه يتم التنسيق فيها
الاجتماع النهائي تدعى لها الدول العربيه
الاعضاء في مجلس الزراعه الداخليه العرب
الدول التي حضرت 14 الدوله ما طبعا احنا
نتكلم مع دول ماجستون الخليجي
هل التمثيل كان كل نفس المستوى نفس نفس
الليفل
اللجنه العليا تشكل وتثبت اعضاء هذه
اللجنه العليا فاللجنه العليا تضم 14 دوله
عربيه لكن احيانا ببعض الاجتماعات مثل هذه
اذا كان في هناك مثل ما يتم طرحها يكون
مثلا
الممثل يتم تخفيض يعني درجه التمثيل اذا
كان هناك بعض الملاحظات مما قد يكون بحثه
او المطلوب يعني
والمرجو تعديله او تطويره في نظام مكافحه
الارهاب لان مجلس وزراء الداخليه العربي
يتميز بعدد من المميزات
ولعلي ادعي الى اني احد منتمي لهذا المجلس
انه من انجح المجلس الوزاريه العربيه
وهناك اليه تحكم الحضور وتحكم المشاركات
لا يمكن ان يكون هناك تمثيل اقل او من
جهات خارج الجهات الامنيه الا اذا نصها في
القرار
الغالبيه الدول تحضر
بالممثلينها طبعا هناك احيانا تكون هناك
اجراءات معينه لبعض الدول ظروف اقتصاديه
تمر بتغيرات وزاريه الى اخر يقل فيها
التمثيل لكن
في العاده 14 دوله اصلا يعتبر في المقياس
العربي حضور كبير لكن هي لجنه عليا تم
تشكيلها
بالتنسيق مع جميع الدول العربيه وتم تحديد
الاشخاص لحضور السبعه اجتماعات المتتاليه
لكي يكون هناك
متابعه لجميع الاجراءات المتخذه استاذ
خالد لو يعني ابرز الملامح اللي هي يعني
انا اعرف انه هو لازال مشروع لم يتم
اقراها حتى يتم عرضه يعني وي من قبل مجلس
الوزراء الداخليه العرب لكن لو تعطيني
ابرز الملامح في هذا يعني انا يهمني اعرف
شو يعني الاطار اللي كان يعني تم النظر
بحاجه الى تطويره في نظام مكافحه الارهاب
العربي
حقيقه الاستراتيجيات تختلف استراتيجيه على
الاخرى الاستراتيجيه العربيه لها عدد من
المقومات والركائز بالاضافه ايضا الى
الاستراتيجيه الخاصه بالامم المتحده قد
يكون الاستراتيجيه العربيه سبقت
استراتيجيه المتحده الاستراتيجيه العربيه
مقره 1997 واستراتيجيه المتحده 2006
وكلتا الاستراتيجيتين تم العمل بموجبه
وهناك بعض الملاحظات وبعض التحفيظات من
الدول او بعض التحديات التي واجهت التنفيذ
هذه الاستراتيجيتين المختلفه عملت اللجنه
العليا على محاوله لموائمه هذه
الاستراتيجيتين لانه في الاخير الهدف واحد
وهو الارهاب والتطرق فعملت على
مواءمه هذه الاستراتيجيه الاستفاده من
المقومات او من
النجاحات التي تحققت ومحاوله لتقريب وجهات
النظر في بعض الاختلافات البينيه حقيقه
ركزت يعني انا ما اقدر اتكلم زي ما تفضلتي
هي هو مشروع
القادم لمجلس الوزراء الداخلي العرب في
غره مارس القادم باذن الله وهناك لجنه
تحضيريه طبعا ستسبق مناقشه
لكن تم التركيز على اربع ركائز اساسيه
تشمل
الوقايه والمنع والمكافحه
والموائمه وبالاضافه هناك نقطه اخيره وهي
قياس مؤشرات الاداء لهذه الاسترات ما تقدر
تعطينا يعني هذه اغلب النقاط الرئيسيه
طبعا لكل لكل ركيزه من هذه الركائز
الاربعه هناك عدد من البنوك عدد من عدد من
النقاط في حاله اقراضها باذن الله من مقام
مجلس الوزراء الداخليه العرب سيتم
تشكيل لجنه لعمل خطط تنفيذيه كعاده مجلس
وزراء الداخليه العربي التعامل مع جميع
الاستراتيجيات كل خطه تنفيذيه ستكون مدتها
ثلاثه اشهر وستعلن في حينه ما هي ابرز
ملامح هذه الخطط التنفيذيه من هنا ابغى
اسمح لي استاذ خالد ادخل معاك في بشكل عام
بقضيه التطرف قضيه الارهاب
احنا نعرف طبعا مثل ما تفضلت ذكرت انه من
العامه
96 كان يعني
مجلس وزراء داخل العرب كان تبنوا كان
قواعد سلوك ثم او استراتيجيه ثم تم
اقرارها في 97
بدايه يمكن احنا يكون متزامن مع اول
تفجيرات اللي كانت في الرياض في ذلك الوقت
من ذلك من ذلك الوقت احنا بنشوف يعني
بفترات متزامنه بتخرج قوائم تصنيف للارهاب
لكيانات واسماء وشخصيات
لكن كيف بتشوف انه التباين ما بين الدول
العربيه والخليجيه في هذه في تصنيف
للجماعات والكيانات
فعلا هو الاستراتيجيه العربيه قامت على
عدد من المعايير ومع
ومنها توحيد الرؤى والتعريفات
ومحاوله
لسد الثغرات التشريعيه والقانونيه الوطنيه
في كل دوله لكي لا يتم استغلالها عبر
الجماعات الارهابيه التي
تحاول استغلال جميع هذه الفجوات ان وجدت
على حسب
التشريعات الوطنيه
حقيقه
لكل دوله في العالم وليس فقط في الوطن
العربي تشريعات واجراءات وطنيه متبعه قامت
الاستراتيجيه على تعزيز التعاون الثنائي
بين الدول
العربيه على توحيد المحاوله لتوحيد
الاجراءات على الاستفاده من الجهود
المميزه او التجارب المميزه لبعض الدول
وعرضها لدول اخرى
للاستفاده منها على
تعزيز تمرير المعلومات والتعاون في انشاء
قواعد معلومات
لمحاوله للوقايه
مثلا احنا نعرف اللي احنا الان في منذ
فتره الربيع العربي في عندنا مسائل وقضايا
مهمه جدا تلح في ملف مكافحه التطرف
الارهاب عندنا مثلا موضوع حركات الاسلام
السياسي او مفهوم الاسلام السياسي وكل من
يندرج وينخرط فيها من حركات والجماعات
سواء
سياسيه او مسلحه وايضا عندنا مثلا الحوثي
عندنا حزب الله في لبنان
فبنتكلم عن مظله الوزراء الداخليه العرب
ونتكلم عن مظله خليجيه هناك تباين كبير في
لكل دوله في كيف يعني تصنف وكيف تفسر
المتطرف والارهاب حسب كل وضع سياسي لكل
دوله فكيف بالامكان ان ننجح في ظل هذه
الاستراتيجيات في ظلها
القوانين والتشريعات التي يتم سنها من
سنوات يعني
صحيح اتفق معك تماما وهذا ما تنبهت لها
الاستراتيجيه العربيه مكافحه الارهاب منذ
بدايه انشائها وحقيقه نجحت في
ايجاد تعريف موحد لمجلس الوزراء الداخلي
العرب للارهاب وتم اقراره من مجلس الوزراء
الداخلي العرب بل ايضا تم اقراره في
الاجتماع المشترك بين وزراء الداخليه
العرب ووزراء العدل العرب في جامعه الدول
العربيه 2001 وتم مصادقه على هذا التعريف
فهناك حد ادنى اللي هو هذا التعريف
لتوحيد الجهود
للمحاربه تبقى هناك اختلافات بين بعض
الدول وهي احيانا قد تكون يعني نوعا ما ما
بقول ايجابيه ولكن
مفهومه ان هناك بعض الدول لها تشريعات لها
انظمه لها
بعض
الاتجاهات المعينه لكن على الاقل يحاول
مجلس الوزراء الداخلي عبر اجهزتها
المختلفه التقليل من اثار هذه التباينات
والمساعده على مكافحه الارهاب ايضا
محاوله عدم استغلال هذه التباين ان وجد
للجماعات الارهابيه ان تستغلوا فهذا الدور
الرئيسي لاي تكتل اي تعاون وهو دور رئيسي
لمجلس وزراء داخل العرب عبر اجهزه مختلفه
عبر الاجتماعات التي تتم من خلاله لكن
هناك
اختلافات هناك قوانين مختلفه في بعض الدول
وهذا ايضا ما لمسناه عند مواءمه
الاستراتيجيه العربيه ما استراتيجيه الامم
المتحده هناك اختلافات كبيره بين بعض
المعايير المتبعه في المتحده
محاوله من الجهاز العلم العربيه للعلوم
الامنيه بايجاد حلول علميه تستند على
ابحاث على دراسات على اراء الدول وتجاربها
ومحاوله تقديم اوراق السياسات ابحاث
دراسات لاثبات
الخطر او نوع الجريمه ومن ثم ابرازه للدول
وتقريب وجهات النظر للاستفاده خالد وحضرتك
وكيل الجامعه للعلاقات الخارجيه ومن ضمن
مهامك اللي يعني
ترتيب اتفاقيات مع منظمات وهيئات الدوليه
مع الامم المتحده وغيرها شو الابرز
الاختلافات اللي حضرتك ذكرتها مثلا في في
مواضيع حقوق الانسان
هناك عدد من
المنظمات الدوليه
لها تعريفات مختلفه في موضوع حقوق الانسان
نحن في الدول العربيه وفي مجلس الوزراء
داخل العرب نرتكز على الشريعه الاسلاميه
التي
من
بداياتها كانت حريصه جدا على حقوق الانسان
حقوق الطفل حقوق المراه في التعامل مع
جميع دون النخل
بالامن فكان هناك بعض
[موسيقى]
التجارب المميزه لبعض الدول تم عرضها
وحقيقه قد تكون بعض الدول مقصره في ايضاح
وجهه النظر او قد تكون هناك اصوات عاليه
لبعض المنظمات الدوليه التي تحاول ان
تستغل بعض
العبارات الرنانه لا اقل والاكثر طيب ابغى
اسالك من ضمن الاشياء اللي انا من متابعتي
مثلا في مواضيع
قضايا الجماعات المسلحه او
يتعلق حتى بطريقه تعاطي الدول الغربيه
فيها هناك يعني عندهم عدم تجريم الراي وان
كان متطرفا الى ان يكون هناك في فعل حمل
سلاح او تصرف فهنا يتدخل القانون كيف
بتعالجوا هالموضوع هذا مع المنظمات
الدوليه ممتاز
انت طلبت مثال وهذا مثال
الفكره تناقض نفسها عندما عندما
تدعي بعض المنظمات انه هناك لا نستطيع
تجريم الراي الى ان يصل للفعل
نثبت عبر الدراسات والابحاث ان الراي يؤدي
الى فعل ونقدم هذه الاراء لانه بعض الاراء
او اغلب الاراء المتطرفه سيكون لها رده
فعل رده الفعل هذه ستخل بالامن وهذا ما
اثبته اغلب الدراسات التي قامت بها جامعه
نايف وحقيقه هناك بعض
النقاط التي اقتنعت فيها بعض المنظمات او
على الاقل عملت بها مؤخرا بعد فتره الربيع
العربي
هناك كثير من
يعني من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين من
حركات الاسلام السياسي يعني اخذت لجوء في
عدد كبير من الدول الاوروبيه منهم على
قوائم دول خليجيه وعربيه في يعني تهم
الارهاب هل هذا كان يعني تم معالجته كيف
تم يعني طرحه مع هذه الهيئات الدوليه
بالضبط احنا في واحد ادوار
التطوير او الاستراتيجيه او تحديث
الاستراتيجيه اللي هو لما يكون عندنا
تعريف موحد للارهاب لما يكون عندها
اجراءات والسياسات متبعه
مقرره عربيا ودوليا ما يخالف ذلك يفترض
انه يكون هناك اجراءات تتخذ سواء عربي او
دوليا اذا كانت هناك اجراءات طبعا هناك
يعني سياده وطنيه وهناك اجراءات وطنيه
مقدره للجميع لكن على الاقل
تبقى في حدود
داخل هذه الوطن دون ان تؤثر لكن هناك
اجماع
عربي وقد يكون هناك اجماع دولي لكن
دعينا يعني
نتفق انه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك اجماع
بغالبيه كامله ارى بعض الدول لديها بعض
الاراء او الانتماءات او سواء دول عربيه
او اجنبيه او منظمات تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
المهم يعني ان لا تؤثر على جهود الدول
الاخرى ايضا لما تنخرط هذه الدول في
التعاون الثنائي او التعاون الاقليمي او
التعاون العربي او التعاون العربي الدولي
بلا شك ستغير من مواقفها
وستثبت لها الايام صحه
مقوله الجموع الجماعه او التجمع ان هذه
الجماعه او تلك تميل الى التطرق من العام
1998 تم توقيع الاتفاقيه العربيه لمكافحه
الارهاب طبعا احنا نتذكر انها في العام
هذا نفسه كانت تفجيرات كينيا وتنزانيا من
قبل تنظيم القاعده وقبلها في ال 97 96 في
الرياض وبعدها في الفين كانت تفجير مدمره
عدد كبير من عمليات ثم خرج لنا تنظيم داعش
يعني شو السبب اللي تشوفه من وجهه نظرك ان
الى اليوم رغم كل يعني مراكز كثيره
لمكافحه الارهاب تم تاسيسها تمويل مالي
ايضا للحرب على الارهاب يعني نتكلم عن جهد
دولي لكن ليش الى اليوم احنا لا زلنا
نواجه هالموضوع هذا وحتى الحده والتطور في
الاصبح مختلف عن السابق
خلينا
يعني نتفق انه الارهاب هو جريمه مثل بقيه
الجرائم والمهددات الامنيه
لمكافحه اي جريمه هناك تحديات وهناك
مهددات
المهددات زي ما ذكرتي تكون الجماعات
الاراء
ولكن نتفق انه انه
الجريمه والارهاب ايضا بصفه خاصه
يحاول ان يتطور او يعيد من تشكيله بين
الفينه والاخرى لاسباب عده
هناك جهات تمول هناك تجاره خصبه لهذا
الجريمه هناك
ايادي خفيه تدعم هنا وهناك هناك ايضا تطور
تقني
تستغل هذه الجماعات كل هذه العوامل تؤدي
الى استمراريه
الجريمه دوره الاستراتيجيات اكتشاف هذه
العوامل تقليل من من اخطارها
كشفها وايضاحها للمجتمع والاجهزه الامنيه
والتعاون في محاربتها
يعني لا نستطيع ان
نتوقع انه انتهاء اي جريمه ومنها الارهاب
لان هناك
جهات كثيره مستفيده من هذا هذه الجريمه
ولكن نحاول تقليل ونحاول تحجيم
ونجحت اجهزه امنيه عربيه ووطنيه ودوليه في
مكافحه والحد
من 97 الى الان هناك سنوات عديده هناك عدد
من الاجراءات الكثيره في عدد كلها
بنيت من خلال هذه الاستراتيجيات من مكافحه
غسل الاموال الاستراتيجيات لتطوير الامن
الفكري
تعاون كثير نتج عن
هناك
دائما
انجازات الاجهزه الامنيه عديده ولكن في
موضوع الارهاب احيانا يعني لا يحب ذكر بعض
النقاط قد انا هذا التوقع
لاسباب اخرى لانها سلسله ومحاوله الى
اللحاق بالطرف الاقوى او الطرف الممول او
الى اساس هذه
الجريمه لكل جريمه في العالم عدد من
النقاط ما قبل واثناء سواء الوقايه او
المكافئ وما بعد الاستراتيجيات تحاول ان
تغطي ما قبل
الوقايه وعبر الامن الفكري نقاط عديده
الاثناء عبر المكافحه والوقايه العسكريه
الامنيه وما بعد عبر
تطوير التشريعات والانظمه
وتعزيز التعاون قبل الاقليم
في 2004 كانت صدر يعني قرار من اعتماد
مجلس الوزراء الداخليه العرب فيما يتعلق
بالتحريض ونشر اي مواد ترويجيه تدعوا يعني
للقيام باعمال ارهابيه او وايضا في 2008
كان تم تعزيز مثل هذا القرار واضيفه يعني
يعني شروحات او توضيحات يعني نقول تفسيريه
اكثر
طبع واعداد مواد او تسجيلات تحرض وتدعوا
للقيام
تشجع يعني ارتكاب اعمال ارهابيه اليوم في
ظل سطوه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بنلاحظ ان هناك
يعني شخصيات قياديه في جماعات ارهابيه
مسلحه تابعه لتنظيم القاعده جبهه النصره
في سوريا في غرب افريقيا
فكيف
تشوف موثقه يعني هذا الحسابات ليس فقط
انها موجوده ولهم حريه الاتصال والتواصل
مع الجمهور العام هي موثقه يعني ان مرخصه
من قبل هذه حتى في التيليجرام في
الانستقرام كلهم موجودين كيف حضرتكم في
هذه القضيه هذه المساله كيف يعني ما مدى
التعاون بينكم وبين الهيئات الدوليه
منظمات الدوليه شو الطرح اللي تقدمها
جامعه نايف في العلوم الامنيه في هالموضوع
هذا حقيقه الجامعه تنفذ الشق العلمي
للاستراتيجيات العربيه والشق العلمي يشمل
العديد من المؤتمرات العلميه والندوات
واللقاءات والد واعداد الدراسات والابحاث
والدراسات
اسمحي لي هنا ايضا اذكر ان مجلس وزراء
الاعلام العرب كلف الجامعه مؤخرا بتحديث
الاستراتيجيه العربيه الاعلاميه لمكافحه
الارهاب والتطرف والجامعه تعمل عليها الان
وبصدد
رفعها لمقام مجلس الوزراء الاعلام العرب
خلال هذا العام باذن الله
وهي مواكبه طبعا الاستراتيجيه
الاستراتيجيه الاولى
كانت الجامعه لها دور فيها اما التحديث
فهو مواكبه لتطور الاعلامي وخاصه مفهوم
الاعلام الجديد واستخدام في في
الجريمه
باذن الله ان تكون هذه الاستراتيجيه جزء
من مساهمات الجامعه في مجال
مكافحه الجريمه عبر الاعلام ومنها الارهاب
ايضا من خلال التعاون الدولي مع المنظمات
ومع الهيئات ومع الشركات العالميه وشركات
المسؤوله عن المنصات التواصل ابراز خطوره
اتاحه مثل هذه المنصات الاجتماعيه
للارهابيين والاستفاده منهم
وهناك جهود بذلت وتبذل لمحاوله ملاحقه
ورصد هذه
[موسيقى]
الامور التي يستغلها الجماعات الارهابيه
اعلاميا تبادلها بين الدول العربيه
ابرازها الى الجهات التي تملك هذه المنصات
المحاوله مستمره ولكن هناك بينكم وبين
المجتمع الدولي استاذ خالد هل يعني لو
تذكر لي مثلا قدمتم مشروع معين لمكتب
الامم المتحده اللي قدمتوا طلبات معينه
اعتراضات معينه على مثل هذه الملاحظات في
في مقر الامان العامه
لمجلس وزراء الداخليه العرب هناك مكتب
للشرطه الجنائيه العربيه ويوثق مع
الانتربول في طبعا من خلال رصد مثل هذه
الاستخدامات المسيئه والرفع بها الى
الجهات ذات العلاقه والى المنظمات الدوليه
ويقوم بدور كامل ويعرض جميع المهام
والاجازات التي يقوم فيها وما حققه من
محاوله
للحد من خطوره هذا هذه المواقف الاعلاميه
على الاجتماعات المتخصصه التي تنظمها
الامانه العامه طب استاذي من الافلام 2013
اقر مجلس وزراء الداخليه العرب
الاستراتيجيه العربيه الامن الفكري طيب
اعتقد 2000 اخر وحده 2016
طيب من ذلك التاريخ وحتى اليوم كيف تقيم
النشاط الثقافي والاعلامي عربيا وخليجيا
في اطار محاربه او الامن الفكري
يعني كيف تقيم الموضوع هذا معالجته ثقافيا
اعلاميا دراميا احد
[موسيقى]
نقاط التي يمكن من خلالها قياس دور
الاستراتيجيات العربيه هي قياس ما قبل
الاستراتيجيه وما بعده
فنجد هناك فرق كبير قد يكون جزء كبير
لفائده هذا القياس لجهود الاستراتيجيه
عمليه الامن الفكري عمليه مستمره وعمليه
طويله المدى
ولها اهداف عديده
وتنخرط فيها مؤسسات امنيه مؤسسات اعلاميه
تربويه
عدد من منظمات المجتمع المدني
وهي عمليه مستمره نتائجها لها نتائج قصيره
ونتائج متوسطه ونتائج بعيده ولكن عمليه
الامن الفكري عمليه كبيره لكن على الاقل
هناك
ثمار من خلال هذه الاستراتيجيه اللي قرها
مجلس الوزراء الداخليه العرب وهناك خطط
هناك الاستراتيجيه لمنع خطاب
الكراهيه كيف تشوف اعلام الاعلام العربي
والخليجي في
يعني بحث مثل هذا في تعزيز الامن الفكري
سواء اذا شفنا المشهد الديني والثقافي او
الدرامي راضي عن
الاعلام الان اصبح مختلف هناك اعلام حكومي
اعلام اجتماعي اعلام خاص
وكل
اعلام السياسه واجراءات اعلاميه
لكن على الاقل على الاقل
الدور هذه الاستراتيجيات وهذه
كشف الغطاء
عدم وقوع يعني وقوع الحجه على على الجهه
لما تستضيف ارهابي او تستضيف كذا في
السابق قد تمرر بعض العبارات او بعض
اللقاءات بحجه عدم فهم الواقع لكن الان
الوضع مكشوف لجميع
سواء المشهد العربي او المسجد الدولي
للاسف الحين لسه في موضوع زلزال اللي وقع
في تركيا وسوريا وشاهدنا الكثير الغثو
السمين من في هالموضوع هذا عاده منصات
لجمع التبرعات بشكل يعني بعيد عن الاطار
المؤسسي الدولي وللاسف يعني في الدول
الخليجيه ودول عربيه يعني ما اتخذت اجراء
في هذا في هذا الاطار
حتى ان بدا الحد الاصوات تدعو الى
المشاركه في الاغاثه والذهاب والمشاركه في
العمل الدعوي هناك وان يعني بحاجه الى
دعاء حتى يربطوا على قلوبهم
بعد الزلزال لكن لازلنا يعني كان المشهد
اللي كان قبل 12 سنه ما بدايه الربيع
الكوارث والازمات
[موسيقى]
تستغل الجريمه ومنظميها والارهاب ومنظمين
مثل هذه المناسبات في اي كارثه في اي ازمه
وما مر وما يسمى الربيع العربي
مثال جيد في مثل هذه
الازمات والتعاطف الشعبي الموجود لدى
الغالب اكيد هناك سيكون هناك اختراقات او
محاوله لهذا الاختراقات
اعتقد ان الاجهزه الامنيه واعيه واعتقد ان
هناك دول قدمت تجربه ثريه
ورائعه مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
في برنامج
الدعم عبر مؤسسه معنيه
وهيئه متطوره وذات باء وعبر منصه حكوميه
للتبرعات
واقفال الاجتهادات الشخصيه التي قد تكون
اما من مدعومه
اجراميه او لا قدر الله هذا يعني نسبه
ضئيله باجتهادات او رده فعل
شعبويه لكن اكيد هناك بعض الجهات ستحاول
الاستغلال هذه الازمات والتعاطف لكن اتوقع
واعتقد ان الاجهزه الامنيه في الدول
العربيه متيقنه تماما بمثل هذه
الامور
لكن مصارح الكوارث دائما تكون
تعج بكثير من الجرائم
انه احنا يعني انت لما تحاصر التطرف
والارهاب في منطقه معينه ويتحرك باريحيه
وبحريه في منطقه مجاوره من عندك حتما انت
يعني لم تغلق يعني يعني لم تضيق عليها من
حيث التمويل لم تضيق عليها من حيث الخطاب
وكانك ما يعني
يعني تاثير عليك بيكون قليل
الاجراءات اللي انت اتخذتها اقصد بتكون
قليله يعني الى يعني يعني
بسبب ضخ اللي ياتيك من الجوار
بيصير الواحد كانه هو يعني لا يبارح
مكانها في هذا الموضوع هذا هذا احد
التحديات الرئيسيه
جميع اغلب قضايا تهريب المخدرات وغسل
الاموال وهي لدعم الجماعات الارهابيه
ولدعم الجريمه عموما
اتفق معك انه هناك بعض المناطق اصبحت ساحه
لهذه
الجماعات الارهابيه وجدت فيها ضالتها
لاسباب عده سواء لفراغ سياسي او اللي
لوجود خلافات او لوجود ازمات او كوارث
سواء طبيعيه او غير طبيعيه
[موسيقى]
الهدف او المقاومه لها تتم عبر التعاون
بين الدول عبر تجريم
وكشف مثل هذه
[موسيقى]
الجماعات
والاستغلال لها لكنها موجوده وستبقى ما
بقيت الاختلافات في
الاراضي الدول وبين المنظمات وبقيت
الكوارث والازمات
شاركت فيها جماعه نايف العلوم الامنيه كان
خطه الخطه العربيه
للحد من انتقال المقاتلين الى مناطق
الصراع او الى مناطق التوتر في المنطقه
العربيه هذا بينقلني ان اتحدث عن موجه
التجنيد
الكبيره اللي يعني استطاع ان يحققها تنظيم
داعش في العراق وسوريا في 2015 احنا نتكلم
عن ثلاثين الف مقاتل انضم لهذا التنظيم
هل ممكن نقول ان هذه الاستراتيجيه العربيه
فشلت
قبل هذا الرقم يعني احنا يعني حتى نسبه
النساء اللي ذهبوا الشباب يعني اطفال
بعوائل كامله
ذهبت الى دوله الخلافهم على مثل ما يسمونه
لا حقيقه
لكن الحقيقه هناك دراسات
اجرت الجامعه سياسات قدمت لاصحاب القرار
وايضا هناك دراسات للواقع عبر الاجهزه
الامنيه العربيه
تبادل المعلومات وللرؤى واجتماعات
ثنائيه واجتماعات عربيه
عرضت وسرحت لمثل هذه الظاهره
ذكرت لك ان هناك الجماعات الارهابيه
والجماعات الاجراميه بشكل عام
تستغل
الازمات وكان هناك ازمه تم استغلالها من
قبل بعض الجماعات لكن لله الحمد استطاعت
الاجهزه الامنيه العربيه ان تتلافى وان
تسد اغلب الثغرات التي تم استغلالها بل
وصلت الى درجه المكافحه
نستطيع ان
نقيم درجه النجاح من الفشل في بدايه
التنظيم والان اعتقد ان هناك نجاح تحقق في
مكافحه والحد من خطر هذه
التجمع على المجتمعات العربيه طيب هذا
بيخليني انتقل الى موضوع قضيه العائدون من
داعش واحنا يعني عندنا
يعني اكبر يعني
مساله مهمه وحرجه بعد القضاء على التنظيم
كابنيه مركزيه او كتنظيم متكامل يعني له
ارض وللو تمويل
الموجودين اللي موجودين في المخيمات اوائل
داعش من اطفال
كثير من يصفها بانها قناه بالموقوته قد
تنفجر في اي وقت نتكلم عن اعداد كبيره جدا
حول 70 الف
هل هناك مبادره عربيه اولا بموضوع اعاده
النساء والاطفال الى دولهم واحنا طبعا
نتكلم ان الاغلب من هذول النساء هم الدول
العربيه واسلاميه وخليجيه
وايضا موضوع التاهيل الفكري
لهذول
للعوائل للنساء والاطفال الموجودين في
مخيمات ودي اعرف شو الدور العربي
مجلس الوزراء الداخليه العرب اللي يعني
قدم فيها الاطار هذا طبعا
للمجلس وعبر
جهازيه جامعه نايف والامانه العامه جهود
كثيره يمكن الوقت ما يسعفني لكن هناك عدد
من الدراسات والابحاث
والاحد اعطيك مثال بسيط كيف التعامل هناك
فرق بين التعامل مع عدم الصراع
طبعا كل الكلام هذا بني على دراسات وابحاث
ميدانيه تم
يعني اختلاف في التعامل معهم سواء الاطفال
او النساء او العائدون الراجعون الى طبعا
المجتمعات يغلب عليها العاطفه انما
الاجهزه الامنيه هناك لها ضوابط ولها
محددات ومؤشرات في اساليب التعاون
والادماج المجتمعي
وايجاد برامج مجتمعيه لادماج هؤلاء
العائدين
مدى التاكد من عدم
عودتهم او انخراطهم لمثل هذه الجماعات
كل ذلك يتم من خلال دراسات وابحاث
ذات واقع ميداني يتم تقديمها لاصحاب الشان
للاجهزه الامنيه وتتم تطبيقها
للتعامل مع مثل هذه
الظروف حقيقه وارجع واكرر تم هناك في عدد
من الدول
برامج للمناصحه للادماج المجتمعي اني
اتكلم عن الان الموجودين في مخيمات
شو المبادره العربيه
والخليجيه للتعامل مع هذا الملف يعني
وكانه ملف مسكوت عنه او يعني من بعض الدول
العربيه انا اكيد ان هناك حراك يعني بيكون
خلف بعيد عن الاعلام وعن الاضواء ولكن
يعني الناس تتساءل يعني وفي نساء دول
عربيه
اسلاميه وكذلك يعني ليش ما يتم اعادتهم
محاكمتهم او يكون هناك شراكه مع الجهات
المعنيه في مثلا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
القصد او مع المجتمع الدولي
تخضع هذه
بعض المخيمات التي ذكرتها وغيرها يخضع
لعدد من الاعتبارات
[موسيقى]
الواقعيه منها
القوانين الوطنيه والقوانين المحليه
وقوانين الدوليه لكن
[موسيقى]
وفق قواعد علميه مدروس ممكن تفصلين اذا
هذه نقطه مهمه
شو الطبيعتي يعني في مثل حالاتها اللي في
المخيمات ايش الدور اللي بيكون فيه هذا
المركز المخيمات تخضع العدد من الاعتبارات
من اعتبارات وطنيه للدول التي فيها هذه
المخيمات اعتبارات دوليه للمنظمات المعنيه
فيها سواء منظمه الدوليه للهجره منظمه
اللاجئين وغيرها اعتبارات امنيه لمدى صحه
هؤلاء
الموجودين انهم مناطق صراع او هناك بعض
الاشخاص
المغروسين بداخلهم اعتبارات عديده كامله
لا يمكن
قد يكون رغبه لدى اي شخص حل السريع لا
يمكن تتم الحل السريع الا وفق معايير
مدروسه وتقوم كل جهه سواء جهاز امني وطني
او التحالفات العربيه سواء الثنائيه او
عبر مجلس وزراء الداخلي العرب او بالتعاون
مع المنظمات الدوليه بادوارها ستتم حل هذه
المشكله لكن لكي نتاكد انه حل ناجع وسليم
لا
يترتب عليه مشاكل امنيه اخرى هذا المركز
بتعاطى او بيتعامل مع الحالات
يعني السعوديه ام انه بيكون مشترك للاعضاء
في الجامعه
من اسمه المركز العربي الفني لاداره
الهجره والحدود معني بجميع مواضيع الهجره
والحدود وامن المنافذ لجميع الدول العربيه
سيقدم
وسياسات والدراسات والادله الدوليه
والاسترشاديه لجميع الاجهزه الامنيه سيقوم
بالتدريب بعقد اللقاءات بالمؤتمرات لجميع
الاجهزه الامنيه في الدول العربيه سواء
عبر برنامج عمل يعد هذا المركز او عبر ما
تطلبها الاجهزه الامنيه العربيه عبر مجلس
الوزراء الداخليه العرب من هذا المركز
هو ومركز اخر لمكافحه المخدرات والجريمه
العابره للحدود التابع لمكتب المتحده
المعني بالمخدرات والجريمه ايضا استضافته
الجامعه
للاستفاده الاجهزه الامنيه العربيه علميا
وفنيا من
الاسر الموجودين الان في مخيمات انا اتكلم
عوائل داعش نساء واطفال نساء
ذهبت مع ازواجها وقتلوا ازواجهم وايضا
الشباب الموجودين هناك هذا هل هو بدايه
لحل موضوع
بالضبط هذه مسائل معقده
جنسياتهم انتماءاتهم مواقعهم لا تحل الا
عبر التنسيق الوطني التنسيق العربي العربي
التنسيق الثنائي والتنسيق مع المنظمات
الدوليه التي لها معايير معينه في حل مثل
هذه الاشكاليات ستتم دراسات مسحيه سيتم
التنسيق فيها
العديد من الاشكاليات التي تم معالجتها من
قبل المنظمه الدوليه للهجره في عدد مختلف
من بؤر الاسراع في العالم ايضا سيتم تطبيق
هذه المعايير على هذه المناطق وغيرها بهذا
السؤال موضوع محاكمتهم هناك طبعا العراق
يعني تحاكم حتى وان كان يعني من جنسيات
اجنبيه اذا كان متورطين في اعمال هل بحثتم
هذا الموضوع
في الجامعه او من خلال الاجتماعات يعني في
هناك شيء جديد في الجامعه هي في مجلس
الوزراء الع دل العرب
[موسيقى]
وتنفذ ما يطلب منها في هذا الجانب من من
من الدراسات او ابحاث
نفذت الجامعه في شهر يناير
من هذا العام
مؤتمر ضخم في المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
عن العداله التصالحيه بمشاركه
فوق يعني تجاوز العدد 570 مشارك من
منسوبي وزارات العدل والنيابات العامه
وعشره نواب عموم عرب كانوا موجودين موضوع
طبعا بعد ان كان هناك موضوع
عقدت فيه الجامعه على مدى اربع سنوات اللي
هو العقوبات
البديله للعقوبات السالبه الحريه الان
موضوع الثاني اللي هو العداله التصالحيه
كلها تهدف في خدمه
التخفيف
الاجهزه العدليه
وتحقيق العداله
والتي هي مسعى لجميع الاجهزه الامنيه
والاجهزه انفاذ القانون والاجهزه العدريه
في
لها ارتباط موضوع الجرائم مكافحه الارهاب
بالنسبه لمواضيع القوانين الوطنيه لكل
دوله تشريعاتها وقوانينها المتبعه قانوني
للمقاتلين الاجانب اللي موجوده هناك من
العراق تحاكم من تورط
فهل هناك يعني مبادره او عمل معين تحت
نظاره يعني وزراء مجلس وزراء داخل العرب
انه توضع اليه معينه بحيث لموضوع المحاكمه
المؤتمرات التي تعقد والاجتماعات
واللقاءات الثنائيه تطرح فيها التجارب
والمعايير الدوليه والمعايير الناجحه في
العالم ويطلب من الجميع
تطبيقها او العمل بموجبها اعتقد كثير من
الاجهزه الامنيه والعدليه استفاده من
المؤتمرات والدراسات والابحاث التي تقدمها
الجامعه بصفتها جهاز علمي لمجلس الوزراء
الداخليه العرب
طيب يعطيك العافيه استاذ خالد وسامحني على
الاطاله معك واسمح لي اختم هنا
قتل ابن لادن والبغدادي والضواهري ودمرت
البنيه المركزيه للقاعده في افغانستان
وتنظيم داعش في العراق وسوريا الا ان ذلك
لم ينهي قصه الحرب العالميه على الارهاب
ولم يقلل من تهديدات خطره فكيف للحكايه ان
تنتهي في ظل تباين سياسي اقليمي ودولي حول
التعريف نفسه ما هو الارهاب ومن هو
المتطرف هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]